cher public d'rtl cher aventuriers ou
pas le temps d j'étais plus rapide sur
cette spéciale c'est terminé
si je vous dis rallye vous me dites
sébastien loeb
didier auriol bruno saby si je vous dis
dakar jamais vous me dites mille et une
nuits et pourtant cette année le rallye
dakar a lieu en arabie saoudite
[Musique]
après dix ans à sillonner les dionne
d'amérique du sud les 4 4 et les baggies
sont donc à ryad alors pourquoi les
organisateurs du dakar ont ils peur de
l'embourbement économique du continent
sud américain ont-ils succombé aux
pétrodollars saoudiens entre ventes
d'armes et à faire rage shoji le royaume
wahhabite est souvent accusé de bafouer
les droits de l'homme et d'entretenir un
islam radical
avec cette nouvelle délocalisation le
dakar a fait tilt fausse route
on en parle après le générique
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt pour un nouvel épisode
de l'autre au match et le dakar 2020
touche à sa fin du côté de l'arabie
saoudite une édition qui fait parler
justement on en parle sur ce plateau
avec nos invités bruno saby 14
participations d'acquérir une victoire
en 93 4 podiums et 15 victoires d'étape
bonjour merci d'être bonjour à vos côtés
pierre conesa ancien haut fonctionnaire
du ministère de la défense spécialiste
de l'arabie saoudite vous avez écrit de
nombreux ouvrages au sujet de ce pays et
notamment docteur saoud et mr jihad la
diplomatie religieuse de l'arabie
saoudite aux éditions robert laffont
bonjour bonjour mais je crois que vous
êtes en train d'écrire un autre livre on
sert sur le lobby saoudien en france
parce que effectivement après laffaire
khashoggi on s'étonne que on enterre une
deuxième fois ce personnage puisque
finalement n'en parle plus donc il ya
bien quelque chose donc cette édition du
dakar en arabie saoudite fait parler
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
d'évoquer la sphère râches oggi par
exemple ou des ventes d'armes ou autre
chose je vous propose ce sondage
effectué sur les réseaux sociaux ou rt
france sur 1700 personnes interrogées 66
personnes répondent oui sur le fait
qu'elles sont choqués sur cette
organisation du dakar en arabie saoudite
34 % répondent non bruno saby est ce que
vous vous êtes choqués alors moi je
demande beaucoup pas savoir sur les
résultats de ça après parce que moi je
côté sportif c'est surtout pour ça que
je suis là je suis un inconditionnel de
ces disciplines parce qu'elle m'a permis
de découvrir le monde entier j'ai eu la
chance grâce au dakar de découvrir
l'afrique
je connais aussi l'amérique du sud
pourrait avoir fait d'autres épreuves
donc ce sont des terrains de jeu idéal
j'ai fait part et moscou pékin donc
traverser la russie l'asie et j'ai
trouvé que c'était une très bonne
initiative que d'aller en arabie
saoudite parce que là j'ai découvert à
travers images un terrain idéal pour
continuer à faire de cette épreuve une
épreuve mythique au niveau de la
découverte et de de la course par elle
même qui est super intéressante sur des
terrains différents et nouveaux donc moi
ce côté sportif donc je peux en parler
après le reste eh bien justement je suis
très très heureux d'étape pour en savoir
un peu plus sur ce pays et je pense que
beaucoup seront intéressés de savoir
comment
a peu évolué grâce à ce genre
d'initiatives alors ça peut être
critiqué on va l'aborder
mais je crois qu'avant tout il faut déjà
découvrir ce pays à travers un événement
sportif pour pouvoir le juger même
question que pour bruno sa vie pierre
conesa êtes vous choqué par cette
organisation en arabie saoudite
moi je suis un peu gêné par nature même
de la question
c'est à dire que le fait qu'une
manifestation sportive se déroule dans
un pays qui effectivement coche tout les
ai toutes les gauches tous les deux les
domaines dès qu'on touche aux patients
des droits de l'homme et de la femme
évidemment encore plus c'est à dire
c'est le pays qui procède le plus à des
décapitations par rapport au nombre
d'habitants ce qu'ils arrivent en tête
devant la chine si vous voulez sur le
nombre de condamnations à mort 180
exécution en 2019 selon la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme
mais moi c'est pas ce chiffre là qui
m'intéressent et par rapport au nombre
d'habitants c'est à dire en chine d'un
milliard deux cents millions d'habitants
dont on dit beaucoup d'exécution mais si
vous voulez rapporté à la population en
arabie saoudite on décapite plus en
arabie saudite quand je suis bon de la
même façon si vous voulez l'arabie
saoudite on connaît la situation des
femmes donc de ce côté là c'est vrai le
pays n'a est un produit abordable
j'insiste sur la bande am parce que
justement c'est là que si vous voulez ce
qu'essaye de faire actuellement mohammed
bin salman le prince héritier c'est
d'essayer de modifier à la marge le
l'image de ce pays et vous comprenez
bien que la tâche est ardue
donc le à la marge c'est justement de
pouvoir attirer dans ce pays des
manifestations qui vont donner le
sentiment quand même que ce pays s'ouvre
sachant que c'est un pays incroyablement
obtus et fermé
n'oubliez pas que les religieux tienne
l'éducation à la justice les
bibliothèques étaient là et que jusqu'à
la décision récente de l'allemagne avait
pas de cinéma d'envoyer le défi c'est à
dire tout à coup ils essayent avec des
actions dont l'objectif politique est
une autre question il essaye d'ouvrir il
essaye de présenter à ces gens un autre
paysage si vous êtes du monde extérieur
dans un enseignement ou évidemment tout
le monde extérieur composé de mécréants
le sport peut ouvrir justement
le pays par exemple au tourisme on peut
espérer c'est vrai qu'à travers les
images que l'on a pu découvrir sur cette
édition
on s'est rendu compte que le pays était
fantastique quoi au niveau bien sûr du
terrain de jeu pour le ceux qui
cherchent ce genre de 2 comment
dirais-je de découverte parce que le
principe du race et ça c'est découvrir
toujours des terrains nouveaux
maintenant pour le tourisme c'est sûr
qu'on ait séduit tous ceux qui en ont
commenté les images on en fait des
éloges donc c'est tentant mais ma
carrière et que c'est possible alors je
pense que le dakar va faire du bien
pour ce qui est de donc de la découverte
du terrain par lui-même des paysages
mais maintenant pour le reste est bien
là justement est fondée par d'ailleurs
qu'ils reconnaissent à pourquoi selon
vous l'arabie saoudite organise-t-elle
des événements sportifs parce qu'il n'ya
pas que le dakar il ya eu également la
la la supercoupe d'espagne ou au mois de
janvier
d'ailleurs remarqué un quotidien
espagnol qui a titré dessus la presse
espagnole pas forcément tendre là dessus
c'est le real madrid 1 pour qui et qui a
gagné face à l'atlético de madrid en
finale il ya eu des matches de boxe avec
un anthony je suis à ya également de la
formule électrique et avoir également du
golf féminin le tournoi de golf féminin
oui c'est pour ça justement pourquoi
pourquoi c'est ce que de l'hypocrisie
c'est ça que j'aimerais savoir y avait
même eu un match de catch féminin mais
avouez le
votre question est d'autant plus
légitime qu effectivement comme j'ai
essayé de vous l'expliquer si vous
voulez mohammed bin salman ne peut pas
toucher aux structures fondamentales de
ce pays ce pays repose sur deux jambes
qui sont évidemment la dynastie des
saoud
mais ils n'ont aucune légitimité
religieuse ils ne sont pas descendant de
la tribu du prophète et leur légitimité
religieuse leur est donnée par les
wahhabites c'est à dire en fait c'est
les descendants des lois d al cheikh qui
se tiend effectivement le grand moufti
l'éducation et tout ce que je vous ai
dis donc
il commence qui peut agir pour
effectivement transformé il ne peut le
faire qu'à la marge
et encore une fois la marche c'est le
divertissement c'est l'ouverture d'un
parc de disney sait des choses si vous
voulez qui effectivement suscite des
réactions
donc c'est le soft power c'est mais
celle du soft power
c'est un sauveteur qui a vocation
évidemment intérieur mais aussi beaucoup
extérieur
parce que ça donne l'image du type qui
est un réformateur est ce que pour
autant il en profite pas pour concentrer
le pouvoir ça on peut le penser par
exemple savez l'opération du ritz dans
laquelle il a réuni tous ses petits
camarades et il aura attiré 60 entre 60
et 100 milliards de dollars en les
obligeant à faire des chèques à pour
sortir c'est une opération qui a été
saluée comme la plus grosse opération
anticorruption de l'histoire d'ailleurs
un bon mais enfin avec un peu d'argent
de poche qui l'a gardée il s'est acheté
un château à l'ancienne et il s'est
acheté un yacht d'un oligarque russe qui
a coûté 800 millions de dollars donc
vous avez toujours cette double double
aspect c'est à dire vous avez vu quelque
chose qui effectivement peut être
médiatiquement saluer mais il faut
creuser un peu derrière pour savoir
quelle est l'intention pourquoi ça fait
tant parler il ya d'autres pays
autoritaires qui ont accueilli des
événements sportifs je pense à
l'argentine de vidailhan 78 je pense à
pékin les jeux olympiques
j'ai eu des manifestations déliter et
des droits de l'homme là on parle
beaucoup ont perdu du soft power n'en
parle de l'argent aussi parce qu'il faut
le dire il ya quand même 15 millions
d'euros par un sur cinq ans et le
contrat avec aso amaury sport
organisation
alors qu'en amérique du sud c'était 2 à
3 millions d'euros par an selon des
informations du parisien
bon c'est une première je crois que ça
va être intéressant d'avoir un peu le
retour de des concurrents déjà
apparemment ils ont l'air contents et
une belle course
on a rarement vu d'ailleurs des amateurs
pouvoir être présent pour la gagne comme
cette année on a eu la victoire de
mathieu serradori avec un buggy privé
est devant des usines
il faut remonter très loin pour
retrouver une telle performance donc ça
veut dire que le terrain de jeu est
idéal alors donc il faut attendre ce
retour traitement le pari est gagné mais
au niveau politique c'est pas ça voilà
vous êtes en train de dire bon nous on
est on est des concurrents on est des
sportifs bon on peut remettre en cause
aussi la discipline
justement justement permettez moi de
vous couper vous dit vous êtes un
sportif il ya également hubert auriol
que vous connaissez bien
une fois le dakar il a été interrogé
deux au rallye connais très bien il a
été interrogé par france info ont
regardé ce qu'il a dit on ne peut pas
demander à des personnes qui participent
à une compétition sportive d'être les
porte parole des problèmes des droits de
l'homme dans ces pays là ce n'est pas
notre rôle c'est quoi le rôle du sportif
c'est simplement se cantonner aux sports
oser avoir un rôle d'exemplarité des
concernés justement moi je c'est pour ça
que je suis très heureux qu'on aborde
ces sujets là parce que je veux en
savoir un peu plus là on est en train
moi je suis en train d'apprendre et on
va approfondir je veux garder le contact
justement avec tous ces sujets là
peut-être que beaucoup de sportifs
ignore et puis honnêtement on y va
peut-être mais peut-être aussi ça va
faire du bien
moi je sais que bon si l'organisateur y
va c'est que lui il s'est qu'il veut
satisfaire des des concurrents qui ont
déjà fait l'afrique dans tous les sens
c'est vrai car on a eu la chance de
découvrir les pays africains suite à ça
d'ailleurs on a pu faire des actions
humanitaires faut pas le négliger en
plus c'est pas ce qu'attend l'arabie
saoudite mais on peut faire des choses
qu'on n'imaginait pas tout le monde a
gardé le contact ou seront découverts
l'afrique grâce au dakar se sont dit
mince il ya des choses comme ici à faire
et combien d'associations se sont créés
moi même j'ai fait les camions de
l'espoir avec jacky ickx pescarolo
lartigue pour essayer d'aider ces pays
là donc
et quel regard est ce que on l'a on
parle de l'arabie saudite qu'elle
regarde ce que vous portez sur
l'organisateur amaury sport organisation
qui a été pointé du doigt notamment par
des députés
régis juanico par exemple qui est député
génération le parti de benoît hamon a
dit j'espère qu'à les sauces et poser
les bonnes questions sur l'attribution
en arabie saudite du dakar quelle
question est quel regard vous portez
justement sur un vaisseau est justement
après avoir traversé dans tous les sens
l'afrique
il fallait voir autre chose après dix
ans il fallait voir autre chose on leur
propose d'arabie saoudite
bon effectivement c'est peut-être pas
complètement sain d'y aller il faut
approfondir et peut-être qu'on en tirera
des enseignements de cette première
édition
on parlait de la sécurité c'est vraiment
injuste une joie une minute sur la votre
question repenser aux jeux olympiques de
36 à berlin on pouvait pas le choix de
trouver meilleur terrain de jeu que
celui du nazisme en plein développement
avec les premières lois antijuives etc
vous avez un individu à sale noir qui va
gagner le 100 m le 200 m le saut en
longueur et les 400 je crois si je me
souviens bien bon et vous savez hitler
qui te quitte le stade puisque sa
thématique c'était la supériorité de la
race blanche et il veut pas saluer jesse
owens donc vous avez là un épisode ou
politiquement vous mettez un pouvoir
face à ses contradictions
donc peut-être débat à l'époque
n'existait pas on met en tout cas ce qui
est intéressant c'est le fait politique
moi ce qui me gêne toujours si vous
voulez c'est qu'on va dire on va prendre
un événement sportif en dix ans mais
pourquoi vous le faites vous bon la
supercoupe d'espagne
c'est sympa mais enfin il aurait pu très
bien le faire ailleurs s'ils l'ont fait
en arabie saoudite personnes s'est lancé
sur la soupe du couple super coupe
d'espagne dans dix ans vous rendez
compte du nombre de journalistes arrêtés
les femmes emprisonnées et c'est donc
sur le dakar c'est peut-être parce que
la visibilité y est plus forte si vous
voulez puis que c'est de la première
mais fondamentalement cette politique
sportive consistant à attirer des
événements sportifs internationaux sur
le territoire d'arabie saoudite
participe de cette politique de mohamed
bin salman encore une fois qui est une
politique à la marge pour essayer de
transformer sa société et dans lequel
effectivement il ya un certain nombre de
jeunes qui vont probablement adhéré au
projet mais moi je serais très heureux
que ce soit une femme qui gagne le dakar
puisqu'il vient d'autoriser les femmes à
conduire des attaques est une femme donc
c'est déjà énorme et vous rendez compte
et pourquoi pas je reviens sur le droit
des femmes qui gagnent un peu la goutte
aussi peut-être messieurs c'est la fin
de la première partie de l'autre match
mais rester sur ce plateau on revient
dans un f3
la deuxième partie de l'autre match est
spécial dakar nos invités sont toujours
présents bruno saby qui a remporté le
dakar en 93 et pierre conesa auteur de
nombreux ouvrages sur l'arabie saoudite
on était en train de parler des femmes
et du dakar jutta kleinschmidt notamment
les femmes souvent pointé du doigt pire
connaisseurs en arabie saoudite
il a eu quatre 14 militants arrêtés en
avril 2019 pour leur soutien aux droits
des femmes selon la ldh la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme
on parle beaucoup des droits de l'homme
l'arabie saoudite qui bafoue les droits
de l'homme quid justement des femmes si
une femme venait à gagner par exemple
c'est d'ailleurs ça va passer mais c'est
un peu paradoxal de parler droits de
l'homme en arabie saoudite parce que
l'homme a tous les droits
nabil saoudite sur la femme c'est un peu
ça le paradoxe il voulait de cette
appellation
c'est qu'effectivement c'est un pays
dans lequel la norme si vous voulez est
basé sur une définition très stricte de
la charia et donc le comment dire la
partie de la population qui est
évidemment la plus méprisée le plus
maltraité ses téléphones donc a été
présenté les décisions doivent être
danse allemande d'autoriser les femmes à
conduire alors que l'arabie saoudite est
le seul pays dans lequel n'avait pas le
droit de conduire
c'est le seul pays du monde bon et donc
ça a été présenté comme une grande
avancée démocratique bonbons direct le
jour où kim jong-hun ouvre un mcdonald's
à pyongyang
on va considérer aussi que la démocratie
progresse donc vous voyez le caractère
bénin de la décision et la façon dont
elle va être surmédiatisée donc moi
évidemment ce qui m'intéresse c'est ça
et à côté de ça vous avez donc ces
femmes qui en aurait réclamé plus sans
dire mais non la véritable réforme c'est
la suppression du tutorat c'est la
suppression de l'obligation de la femme
d'être automatiquement sous l'autorité
de son mari pour se déplacer etc
vous avez par exemple que les gaffes à
ont développé un an des remises dans
leur système un logiciel qui permet qui
se met sur le téléphone de la femme et
qui permet à l'homme de toujours savoir
où aller et vous de voir la campagne de
presse chez nous' existent peut aussi se
compte surveiller ses du bnb si vous
voulez et donc on est dans cette
situation là ces femmes qui ont protesté
justement pour la suppression du temps
tu été immédiatement arrêtée emprisonnée
elle font toujours si vous voulez des en
détention donc si vous voulez encore une
fois cette cette situation j'espère que
les femmes
qui font le dakar vont donner une espèce
de gifle à tous et religieux ses talents
vont gagner
elles ont elles l'ont dit en tous les
cas l on dit ça peut permettre au pays
de s'émanciper on peut regarder le tweet
de life idh1 qui parle justement de ces
chiffres concernant les femmes mais
également les exécutions 180 exécution
en 2019 des peines de porc la des peines
de mort la répression judiciaire
exécutions de masse oppression des
femmes lundi détention arbitraire quand
on voit ce genre de chiffres et dannon
ça vous fait quoi à bruno crémer de moi
d'avoir je reviendrai sur sword est
justement la victoire d'une femme soldat
car rendez compte que l'organisateur a
permis de faire admettre qu'une femme
pouvait gagner dakar au départ ça
paraissait comme une preuve impossible
un surhumaine qui a été faite que pour
les hommes et une femme justement est
arrivé à démontrer le contraire on en a
vus en moto faire des performances
jutta kleinschmidt entre autres est bien
là est arrivé en voiture à gagner donc
c'est une étape c'est déjà pour les
féministes c'est fantastique
alors pourquoi pas pour le reste c'était
une étape je trouve moi pour les femmes
en tous les cas il ya un homme qui
compétitive pour la gagne peut-être
va-t-il gagner on arrive à la fin du
dakar cette année ou peut-être ne
gagnera t-il pas peut-être gagnera-t-il
et les éditions suivantes puisque c'est
pendant cinq ans donc j'ai encore quatre
éditions sur la péninsule arabique
c'est nasser al attiyah c1 qatariens on
sait que entre doha et riad pierre
connais ça c'est pas le corps d'un mois
non c'est pas un vain mot
vous savez le qatar et hommes ce qu'on
pourrait dire un nouveau lot riches
c'est à dire c'est un pays qui s'est
soudainement brutalement et
extraordinairement enrichi quand on a
découvert la nappe de pétrole de gaz
qu'ils partagent avec les remparts est
donc ce pays s'est comporté comme un
nouveau riche c'est à dire que sa
visibilité internationale s'est acquise
à coup de carnets de chèques non c'était
la diplomatie du carnet de chèques
ici à paris un certain nombre de députés
dont certains qui ont changé de bord
depuis son réal et s'est demandé de
l'argent comme une ancienne ministre est
allé demander trois cent mille euros
pour faire une manifestation de familles
dans le golfe par exemple pas donc ça le
jour où mme chesnot et malbrunot sorti
un bouquin sur le qatar si vous laissez
à tétaniser le système mais saoudiens
sont très jaloux de cet entrisme du
qatar absolument partout parce que c'est
le petit le nain le qatar n'existait pas
avant la découverte de ce et donc toute
cette politique qui a consisté à vouloir
faire la coupe du monde au qatar à faire
des tas de choses à créer un musée des
arts islamiques et c'est irrite
profondément celui qui se considère
comme le grand frère c'est à dire
l'arabie saoudite et donc on est dans
cette situation où effectivement si un
qatarien qui a déjà gagné le dakar vient
en plus et le gagner sur le territoire
de l'arabie saoudite
qu'est ce qui va se passer ça participe
c'est la même voie aux bleus c'est la
fin je pense que pour les femmes
séparées qui est là parce que c'est un
sportif il est idée considérée comme
telle il était inquiet au départ quand
on lui a dit le rallye va se faire en
arabie saoudite
lui il avait peur de ne pas être
justement à noter pour le faire donc ça
c'était ouvert c'est déjà une étape
après c'est un garçon qui fait les jeux
olympiques aussi qu'à d'autres qualités
si c'est un vrai sportif donc lui il
accepte le terrain qu'on lui propose
maintenant si s'il le gagne
qu'est ce qui va se passer l'utilisation
politique qui peut être amusante après
parce que l'homme ne risque rien il ya
des pèlerins qatarien qui vient de faire
le pèlerinage tous les ans donc c'est
pas l'homme à la volée c'est le sac de
la symbolique politique dans ces deux
pays qui ont un quotient comme chiens et
chats la fin il ya un gros chien lucky
chaque coin vous avez évoqué le nom
d'une personne c'est georges malbrunot
qui travaillaient pour le figaro qui a
sorti un article récemment il parlait
des relations entre paris et et ryad pas
d' échanges diplomatiques lors des 18
derniers mois c'est qu'il l'a fait
rachel j ai eu l affaire des ventes
d'armes jean yves le drian ou encore
florence parly ont parlé à ce niveau là
les ministres français de l'alliance et
et désarmé le fait qu'ils aient pas
d'échangé automatique depuis 18 mois
s'il ya quoi l affaire a choisi et la
sphère des ventes d'armes avec la sphère
disclose france info concernant des
armes qui devait arriver en arabie
saoudite et être potentiellement utilisé
au yémen sur des populations civiles que
de toute façon la sphère fashion j ai
provoqué une espèce de séisme médiatique
heureusement bon moi ce qui m'ennuie
c'est qu'il ya pas de réplique c'est à
dire que je n'en parle plus mais vous
savez de la négociation bilatérale est
une négociation multidomaine c'est à
dire que vous avez tout à la fois jean
nouvel qui travaillent sur le projet
d'al oula vous avez le projet de
construction du métro de médine et de la
mecque
vous avez des négociations de bouygues
pour construire des immeubles et
évidemment c'est les formes d'armes sur
lesquelles on va prendre l'indicateur
politique mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
n'y a plus aucun français qui vont en
arabie saoudite simplement qu'il ait pas
de programme en négociation aujourd'hui
en tout cas rien qui soit à maturité et
qui justifie un déplacement politique
mois pour avoir été à l'intérieur c'est
vrai ça ne m'étonne pas trop
maintenant est-ce qu'on est dans une
période de froid au point que
effectivement on va comment dire perdre
un certain nombre d'enjeux importants
je n'en sais strictement rien vous savez
pendant longtemps les hommes d'affaires
venez voir l'administration en disant
oui mais là on est prêt la négociation
et patsy le ministre y va c'est bon
aussi bon et puis vous avez été admise
qui sont allés sur place et qui n'ont
pas signé
donc le l'indicateur des échanges
diplomatiques n'est pas automatiquement
le bon indicateur de l'état des
relations
on a parlé de l'état du dakar en arabie
saoudite on peut parler de l'impact du
dakar au niveau de l'environnement
également je propose de regarder ce
sujet il est signé clément delcourt 351
équipage 7800 km dans des véhicules
surpuissants le dakar est loin de l'idée
qu'on peut avoir d'un sport écologique
chaque élection l'événement émet environ
40 mille tonnes de co2 soit un peu moins
de 40 milles aller retour paris moscou
l'association agir pour l'environnement
met aussi en avant l'influencé
catastrophique que peut avoir la course
sur des écosystèmes fragiles et la
destruction de sites historiques
l'organisation se défend et met en avant
ses préoccupations environnementales
nouvelle technologie tri sélectif sur
les bivouacs ou encore une compensation
financière de l'impact carbone au profit
d'une ong
mais est ce bien suffisant alors que
l'année 2010 9 vient d'être enregistrée
comme la deuxième année la plus chaude
de l'histoire
alors que l'australie brûle alors que la
masse denis brûlent également un impact
carbone comme celui ci est ce que ça
vous choque pour nous a dit non parce
que bon l état de témoignages on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui peuvent
puisque ça bien sûr il faut reconnaître
que ça peut plus un petit peu mais ce
n'est rien par rapport à tout le reste
par rapport à ce que voulaient les
cargos polluent et puis et c'est qu'on
peut aborder le sujet en débatte pendant
très longtemps
moi ce qui me gêne par contre c'est que
en charge les participants moi je
connais cette catégorie de personnes ce
sont des gens qui pensent qu'ils sont
bien ce sont des gens intelligents ils
sont une passion voilà ils ont une
passion c'est le sport mécanique
alors ils font de la moto il fonde la
voiture il ya quelques aventuriers qui
viennent de temps en temps se greffer à
cette discipline cette année on a une
maille cornes
ce qui me gêne c'est qu'on attaque ce
garçon là quoi justement il n'a que
respecter un garçon comme mike horn il
fait beaucoup aussi pour l'environnement
c'est un garçon exemplaire parce qu'il a
eu l'audace le courage de da d'affronter
le monde entier et on sait de quelle
façon
donc il vient faire un test sur une
épreuve
il accepte parce qu'elle veut découvrir
aussi veut connaître lui aussi son
témoignage très intéressant je crois
qu'il faut échanger avant de pouvoir
justement chargé des gens comme ça
justement il s'est défendu par rapport à
toutes les critiques qu'il a reçues
malicorne je vous propose de regarder
son témoignage cela ne va pas changer ma
manière de vivre et la manière dont j'ai
envie de vivre je n'ai pas besoin de me
justifier mais j'essaie aussi à travers
ces reproches d'éduquer selon vous une
idée du pays qui baissent et témoignages
tout ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à présent ont
été admirés 106 lits sensibilise les
jeunes tous ceux qui ont la
préoccupation de l'environnement de la
nature sous ces témoignages sont
intéressants c'est quelqu'un quelqu'un
qui sait de quoi il parle et il s il
n'est pas indifférent à tout cela tout
l'écosystème puisqu'il fait des actions
derrière donc il va en tirer les
enseignements
son voyage en arabie saoudite quelques
c'est peut-être déjà avant et connaît le
désert mais là à mon avis il en aura
encore plus de détails à donner et
j'attends avec impatience de rencontrer
cet homme que j'admire pour pouvoir
justement savoir exactement ce qu'il en
pense
et puis avoir des témoignages de ce
genre d'aventuriers à mon avis ça peut
être intéressant qui reconnaissent à
l'arabie saoudite que fait-elle par
rapport au climat on vient d'évoquer
l'impact l'environnement dakar l'arabie
saoudite et le climat c'est quoi robin
d'abord c'est un climat hivernal comme
ça qu'il faut reconnaître c'est à dire
que je voulais un des paradoxes des
attentats dans certains cantons a
retrouvé le testament de mohamed attia
le leader du groupe
ils écrivent elles sont allées au
paradis et le paradis c'était vous savez
les femmes et l'alcool est par contre
évidemment l'enfer c'est la chaleur elle
est le désert bon si vous renversez ça
ça veut dire que pour un saoudien
aujourd'hui l'enfer sur terre c'est
l'arabie saoudite et le paradis sur
terre c'est les états unis en fait
j'arrête sur sept ce psychodrame cette
espèce de schizophrénie
aujourd'hui l'arabie saoudite est
évidemment à cause de son climat obligés
d'avoir des choses extrêmement polluante
d'avoir des véhicules puissants pour
aller dans le désert d'avoir des l'air
conditionné dans des tours qui sont
probablement pas très bien isoler et
c'est donc le bilan carbone de l'arabie
saoudite c'est très difficile en plus je
crois pas qu'ils éléments les éléments
statistiques si vous voulez pour la
mesurer
enfin n'oublions pas que quand on parle
de l'environnement on peut toujours
trouver un argument expliquant que
l'autre se comporte mal celui qui
aujourd'hui refusent renoncer au
protocole de paris c'est d'abord donald
trump
c'est à dire qui dit l'amérique ne
respectera pas les obligations
internationales vous rendez compte c'est
à autre chose que l'arabie saoudite
bon donc on est sur quelque chose si
vous voulez encore une fois ou dans le
domaine de l'environnement
ça part un peu dans tous les sens c'est
à dire regardez il ya ça regardez à ça
les sports mécaniques police oui ça
c'est vrai ils ont organisé d'ailleurs
une semoule accepte mais il ya beaucoup
d'efforts qui sont faits il ya beaucoup
de nouvelles technologies de 2 qui
arrive grâce au sport automobile
et peut-être que ça permettra justement
à l'avenir de l'automobile de survivre
ils ont faire une course d'ailleurs de
la compétition et ça c'est pour ça c'est
l'intérêt aussi de notre discipline
c'est permettent de développer les
énergies nouvelles le mot de la fin
messieurs si vous en avez un mât moi
pour ma part je me permettrais de dire
que tout ça m'a fait découvrir ce pays
que je ne connaissais pas et j'attends
avec impatience justement comme donne
des explications sur tout ce qu on peut
critiquer
et je suis prêt à partager et à accepter
ces critiques mais moi sur le côté
sportif j'ai vu des choses
extraordinaires
j'espère que le dakar sera toujours dans
cette dans cette vocation de faire
découvrir des nouveaux continents
dhainaut des nouveaux pays et peut-être
contribué justement à au développement
de pays comme ça qui sont critiqués
apparemment justifier votre mois de la
fin ne faut pas un ailier la
responsabilité des politiques c'est à
dire qu'on peut pas prendre des
manifestations dont ça c'est pas bien ça
c'est pas bien ça sera bien n'oubliez
pas quand même que l'arabie saoudite est
notre premier client en matière
d'armement depuis pratiquement un moyen
de lycée depuis 25 ans qu on a des tas
de contrat et c'est sur place et donc
que si vous voulez on pourrait très bien
me dire ça et ça et ça et ça et ça et ça
c'est pas bien simplement soyons
cohérents sur la totalité le dakar à mon
avis n'est qu'un épiphénomène dans une
relation s'il voulait il y aurait
beaucoup de sujets beaucoup de sujets
beaucoup plus graves à traiter dans la
transformation de l'arabie saoudite
merci beaucoup monsieur d'être venu sur
le plateau de l'autre match pour parler
donc du dakar vous êtes évidemment les
bienvenus sur ce plateau
cette émission est à revoir en podcast
ou en replay sur rt france points à tv
line on se donne rendez vous la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle émission un
nouveau match l'autre match sur rtl
france
[Musique]
oh